[Musique]
l'assemblée du conseil départemental des
Jeunes élisé ce matin leur nouveau
président 16 candidats en LCE ont pris
la parole devant les conseillers jeunes
pour présenter leur projets nous aussi
nous aussi
onur on a drit VI professionnale
professionnelle familiale les 61
conseillers des collèges présents ont
ensuite voter et c'est Mathis Grondin du
collège de Bernica Saint-Paul qui
remporte cette élection point principaux
de mes de mon programme c'est la mise en
valeur de notre patrimoine réunionné
parce que pour moi c'est une fierté
d'être réunionné et je veux que tous les
jeunes qui grandissent aujourd'hui à la
Réunion soient aussi fier l'écologie
parce que je pense que la base de notre
île c'est l'écologie nous Vions en plein
en plein milieu de la nature CDJ ça nous
permet d'être acteur de notre propre vie
de s'investir dans la vie de notre cité
du département de de créer haut et fort
nos opinions de n'avoir pas peur de de
partager ces ces opinions de de poser
des questions en fait de débattre sur
différentes thématiques et ça vraiment
ça nous fait grandir ça ça nous prépare
peut-être à la vie politique pour ceux
qui veulent se lancé et c'est vraiment
une expérience enrichissante qui est
formidable de nouvelles vice-présidentes
paillette May et paillette Lilou
complètent le nouveau bureau le CDJ
continuera à pororter des actions de
sensibilisation auprès des jeunes sur
des problématiques de société bon
certaines sont très connues comme
l'arsellement scolaire l'égalité fille
garçon les violences intrafamiliales
pour C pour citer un petit peu des des
problématiques qui qui reviennent
régulièrement et donc sur lesquels on on
les incite à travailler à réfléchir à
proposer des actions en matière de
prévention notamment parce que c'est
surtout ça qui qui est important la
communication prévention à mener au sein
des
[Musique]
établissements